yeah we've got these the latest figures
now the results of this year's a-level
exams and it's been a record-breaking
year we now know that
98.3 percent have passed a levels with
nine percent getting that top grade of a
star these are record-breaking figures
but of course
very few people are looking at this
today lots of people are looking at this
system because this is no ordinary exam
yet it's been an exceptional year
not a single exam has been taken they've
instead been using this moderating
system based on
the predicted grades by teachers and
although if you look at one of the
figures which
suggests and shows us that over 94
percent of students
have their grade that as predicted by
their teacher that's the grade they're
receiving today 35.1
of students have had that at that grade
down graded now the exam boards say this
has made no difference to the overall
trends we're seeing exactly the same
patterns that we've seen
in previous years but over one in three
of those results
are lower than the grade that was given
the grade that was predicted
by the teachers ofqual the exams
watchdog says that
their analysis shows that there is no
negative bias when it comes to
socioeconomic background when it comes
to gender
when it comes to ethnicity but already
the unions are complaining they're
saying they're hearing already
very early on heartbreaking stories from
schools from colleges
who say that they are noticing
unfathomable unfairness in their results
and as we heard yesterday there are now
options in terms of that appeals process
students themselves aren't able to
appeal against results but they can
through their school through their
college
launch and appeal and that appeal could
be based on their mock results
again another area of controversy
because this is a very unregulated area
and as yet we don't even know the
details surrounding how those mock
results will be looked at how they might
be taken into consideration
that is something offcore will have to
be looking at and they haven't been
given long to do that we only heard
about this yesterday
schools can also say well look we've had
a change of head we've got a change of
structure in our school
that historic data you've based it on
the last three years sets of results
is no longer valid that's why we want
these results looked at
and also students have this option of
taking exams
come the autumn as well should they need
to but of course these are students
who've had six months off school six
months without lessons
it's an even incredibly stressful time
for them are they going to want to reset
to retake an
exam that was cancelled way back in the
middle of march
well if you wanted evidence of the of
the problems that may exist
with the appeals process and the lack of
clarity the lack of detail
listen to this from our colleague jackie
bell trow she's tweeted the following
dear boris johnson dear gavin williamson
my son got a star a star a in his mocks
however the government adjudicators
algorithms have downgraded his a
to b the school don't know how to make
his mocks the official grades
you must explain there will be plenty of
people asking the government one key
question why are we having to wait till
next week to find out the criteria
on which off quo will decide whether a
mock is valid or not
i know because it's been a hideously
long wait and anxious time and agonizing
wait for students already
and yet we've still got days and days of
this now
what ucas and universities are saying is
that we will be flexible when it comes
to university admissions but
in a way it's all very well to get the
university place maybe with the lower
grades than you were offered
for the offer but for many students it's
a matter of pride it's a matter of
getting the grades they believe they
deserve
they believe those two years of work
should let them have and that's where it
becomes trickier now as i say overall
the trends in terms of the grade and the
distribution of grades
remains the same but there are going to
be in a generic system a general system
assessing thousands and thousands of
individuals there will be situations
where you get pupils who feel they've
been unfairly treated and there have
been examples and people who are worried
where
if they're exceptional students in
perhaps a school that is
less high achieving that they will be
automatically downgraded by schools
we're going to get more detail more
analysis of how ofqual
have come up with the details in terms
of the lack of negative bias they say
later in the day but this is far from
over and and the the clearing the ucas
website the clearing
phone lines are already very busy and
the appeals process has yet to start